protesters against military rule in
sudan facing tear gas and live
ammunition by security forces those
injured are rushed on motorbikes to
hospital where medics most of whom are
volunteers try to provide assistance
i was in front of the protest tear gas
was fired at protesters and i got hit by
a canister it hit me right behind my
left ear
there were shots fired on one of the
streets when we were retreating from the
security forces i got grazed by a bullet
in my head and was rushed to the
hospital
since october last year protesters have
been taken to the streets to voice their
anger against a military takeover which
resulted in the dissolution of a
two-year transitional government meant
to lead sudan to democracy security
services have repeatedly used tear gas
and live ammunition against unarmed
civilians the u.n and other
international bodies have condemned the
use of force which it describes as
excessive
its human rights office says tear gas
canisters fired directly at protesters
is a violation of international
standards
at least seven protesters were killed in
the previous protests to the
presidential palace but that has not
deterred protesters who continue to take
to the street at least 72 people have
been killed in such protests since they
take over three months ago more than 2
000 have been injured
but getting treatment is not easy
ambulances are repeatedly blocked from
reaching those injured hospitals have
been raided by security forces with tear
gas fired inside them and protesters
have even been arrested while receiving
treatment inside hospitals
those who are already sick and bleeding
when the attacks happen and the tear gas
is fired it terrorizes the staff the
medics come to provide assistance and
the attacks make it hard to continue
working until the situation passes
that could be half an hour or an hour
and sometimes we're forced to transfer
patients because of the lack of security
sudan's military-led governing body the
sovereignty council has promised to
protect hospitals and medical facilities
during protests but those on the streets
want the council gone and want
accountability for the lives lost and
those injured demanding a civilian rule
heber morgan al-jazeera cartoon